hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar the
latest developments
for enriching and analyzing antigen and
virus-specific
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by miltoni biotek
to learn more visit miltonibbiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window i'd like to now
welcome our speaker
lorenz fola the global product manager
for antigen and virus specific t cells
at miltoni biotech
friends you may now begin your
presentation welcome
[Music]
and welcome again today's webinar on our
latest developments for enriching
and analyzing antigen and virus-specific
t-cells i'm lawrence and i'm a global
product manager here at milton e
and in today's webinar i will introduce
to you our
complete workflow so from sample
preparation to analysis
to work with this very rare but at the
at the same time also very important
t cells so also in regard to the
experiment experimental workflow
we had multi-biotech strongly believe
that the future of t-cell analysis has
to be more standardized
to generate more robust and also
comparable results
so enjoy before i dive
really deep into the topic i want to
quickly highlight a new product
this ask of two t-cell analysis kits
that were released in december last year
these kits enable an efficient
stimulation
and sensitive detection of the ask of
two reactive t cells in human pvmc
samples
the presence of these ask of directive t
cells and donor samples
then indicate an exposure of the donor
to disaster of two virus
and the kep the kids are really designed
to be an all-in-one solution and they
contain everything so antibodies
stimulation reagents controls
buffers and also protocol so if you want
to know more about the kids
you have to stay tuned so here you can
see
today's agenda so i will firstly um
discuss the important role of t-cells
and covet 19
and also more general viral infections
and then also talk about some strategies
on how to best analyze them
next i will talk about some of the key
challenges when working with these rare
t-cells
and also how miltoni and our products
can help you
overcome those challenges i will end
with a short look
beyond t-cells and virus research and
present our new
recombinants ask of two proteins that
can be used for example for the analysis
of zask of two specific b cells
so comet 19 has been really an
unprecedented global challenge
and we think only together we can defeat
covet 19
and return to a let's say more normal
life
so just as a quick repetition zaskov2 is
the virus
that causes the respiratory illness
covet 19.
and still dusk of 2 still exhibits very
high infection rates and also numbers of
cases worldwide
in general covet 19 has a very
broad spectrum of disease severity and
symptoms
and the symptoms range from asymptomatic
or mild to really
life-threatening illness especially of
course in groups of high risk
and the control measures such as
lockdowns or social distancing
had and still have very severe social
and economic consequences and this is
exactly why we need more tools for an
efficient and precise diagnosis of covet
19
to then hopefully boost the development
of more effective therapies
and as dr anthony fauci the the chief
biologist of the u.s government recently
said on a
on a keystone's keystone symposia
unprecedented progress has been made but
much more needs to be done
so consequently also mentioned in
biotech will do its best to support your
virus-specific t-cell research
so there also also some good news and
this is that effective vaccines have
been improved by various
regulatory agencies and they're also
currently being rolled out
so while all of these approved vaccines
are more or less really high effective
i've brought you just some examples to
demonstrate
the effectiveness of some of these
vaccines so for example
here here on the left you can see the
the the pfizer biometric vaccine and
also the the modern vaccine in the
middle and they actually show a
protection of up to 95 percent in
vaccinated people
and here on the right i've selected an
important publication from the so-called
oxford coveted vaccine trial group that
analyzed immune responses in people that
received the vaccine from astrazeneca
and as you can see vaccination actually
induced both
so very strong antibody response as well
as a strong t cell response
so now now you might ask why do we
actually need to study t
cells especially in covid19 in more
detail
well first of all of course because we
simply need
a more accurate picture of the ask of
two immune responses
and just as a note i really have to say
for me it's absolutely amazing how many
studies are currently being conducted
to uh to disentangle the immune
responses to zaskof2
but let's have a look at some of the key
findings so for example
it has been shown 10 to 30 percent of
patients do not produce
detect detectable levels of the ask of
two specific antibodies
and furthermore in patients with
asymptomatic or mild disease the
antibody titus are actually really low
and also rapidly decline
in contrast it has been shown that the
ask of two reactive t
cells are generated even the absence of
virus specific antibodies
so for example in this in this figure
from a study by
sikhinet al published in 2020 you can
see
that t-cell responses were detected more
frequently
compared to virus-specific antibodies
particularly in cases of mild infection
shown here in
in red and in this greenish
also importantly the analysis of
zarskov2rectivet
cells can also be used to monitor
long-term immunity
be it after natural infection or also
after vaccination
and also particularly in regard to
vaccines it will be very important
to study the implications of
cross-reactive t cells
so these are t cells that were
originally generated against our
coronaviruses for example
for the design and analysis of all the
upcoming trials that investigate forward
19 vaccines
and last but not least also the sask of
directive t cells
can be generated and also used as a
treatment option for example in passive
immunization
and down here on the bottom you can also
click
on on these selected references that
um that i picked here so why are
especially t
cells so fundamental for an efficient
antivirus immune response in general
so apart from the the innate immune
system and the visa mediated antibody
responses t cells really play a central
role in the organism's antivirus defense
and of course all these parts so innate
immune responses rumor and immune
responses
are strongly interdependent and also
need to work together
efficiently to generate antiviral immune
responses
however i just want to point out that
only assessing antibody titres after
infection will not result in a full
picture
and this is exactly why we need to have
a look at virus-specific t-cell
responses
so why are virus-specific t-cells so
fundamental for the immune response
well of course they not only kill
virus-infected cells directly but also
support visa responses
and most importantly virus-specific
t-cells provide long-term immunity
and are therefore um relevant
um for for for favorable disease
progress
and also to have to have a better
prognosis of disease so
now we can have a look at how to best
analyze these antigen virus specific t
cells well generally the methods can be
classified into two main categories
so first there are the direct analysis
methods where we analyze t-cell
specificity with
mhc multimeters for example and here
the adhesive receptor is labeled with a
peptide mhc multimeter complex to
directly identify
antigen or virus-specific t-cells and
although these
methods are certainly have a very high
specificity
they also come with some limitations for
example they work really good for c8
positive t cells but only very limited
for cd4 positive t
cells there's also no info on the
functional capacity or the t-cell subset
and it's also limited to defined
peptides yeah let's say
antigenic epitopes and and mhc molecules
and then second there are the indirect
analysis methods
and here more functional parameters such
as for example the expression of certain
activation markers or cytokines
but also for example cytotoxicity or
proliferation can be analyzed
so you have to understand that these are
indirect readouts for t
cells that were stimulated for example
with a specific peptide antigen
suitable activation markers that could
be analyzed are for example cd69
cd 137 or c154
or also cytokines like interleukin-2
gene of alpha or gamma interferon
so these methods have the advantage that
they really work
well for all t-cell subsets also
including regulatory t-cells
they provide substance-specific
information and are also completely
independent of the used antigen or the
mhc status of the donor
most importantly however the biggest
advantage of these indirect methods
is that all relevant information can be
obtained using flow cytometry
based essays so for today's webinar i
will focus on these these indirect
analysis methods
so but let's first have a quick look
into the key challenges that arise
when working with these rare cells and
how we can help you
to overcome them so as briefly mentioned
before
the low frequency of these rare antigen
and virus-specific t-cells is definitely
the biggest challenge
for a reliable analysis all the more
it is really important to optimally
prepare the starting material without
losing any of these pressure cells
furthermore to ensure higher cell
numbers the cells can also be
pre-enriched magnetically or via flow
sorting
another common problem is insufficient
stimulation
and only by using really powerful
reagents and also optimized protocols
the cells will be efficiently stimulated
furthermore the analysis is off the hem
part by high background staining
and this is mostly just because the
cells are just so rare
and here reagents for specific labeling
and also
really sensitive detection methods can
help to to lower the background
and finally there's often a rather slow
translation of these findings into the
clinic
and here milton offers a large portfolio
for translational research that could
also help you to speed up this process
so to efficiently isolate stimulate
stain and analyze antigen and virus
specific t
cells we combine different technologies
over an entire workflow to ensure
successful experiments yeah and of
course we think
that the right product combination here
is the key to success
so now let's let's have a quick look on
the workflow that can be applied for the
analysis of antigen and virus specific t
cells
so first the t cells need to be isolated
from a donor samples
and this could be blood or tissue for
tissue dissociation of course you can
use our
gentlemax fissure dissociator which is a
really good choice
please note that for the analysis of
antigen and virus specific t cells you
also need
antigen presenting cells because they
efficiently prime and activate
the t cells with a certain antigen when
working with pbmcs for example this is
already the case
however with isolated t-cells from
tissues antigen-presenting cells have to
be added separately to the culture
next the cells need to be efficiently
stimulated with the antigen of interest
for example
using our large portfolio of zarskov to
peptivator peptide pools
following the stimulation the
antigen-specific t-cells will get
activated and upper regulate certain
certain activation markers and also
start to secrete cytokines
the cells can then be stained intra and
extracellularity to assess the phenotype
and also analyze cytokine expression
before the analysis these rare
antigen-specific t-cells that were
activated can also be pre-enriched
magnetically
and finally the cells will then be
analyzed for example via flow cytometry
or further sorted on a on a specific
cell structure
and you can find a very good overview of
the whole antigen and virus specific t
cell workflows including including
protocols and other product solutions
on our application websites by following
these
these links here in the bottom so now we
will
quickly go through the different steps
of this of this workflow
and of course successful experiments and
you you probably better notice than than
me
always start with sufficient sample
preparation
and one of the most widely used sources
for antigen and virus specific t
cells are still pbmcs because they
actually contain
both the antigen-specific t cells as
well as the antigen presenting cells
and thereby pbmcs actually provide let's
say a functional immunological context
for the immediate analysis of
antigen-specific t-cell responses
so usually pbmcs are prepared via
density gradient centrifugation
however when working with for example
contaminated samples some are
compromised samples very small samples
or very rare cells
density gradient centrifugation can be
very tedious
inefficient and in some cases even
dangerous
so and this is where our max prep pbmc
isolation kit comes in the max prep pvmc
isolation kit provides a very fast and
untouched
this is very important untouched
isolation of highly pure pbmcs with a
high recovery
the kit is optimized for small blood
samples of 1 to 10 ml
and does not require lysis of red blood
cells or even density gradient
centrifugation
the isolated cells are perfectly suited
for downstream analysis and you can even
process
multiple samples in parallel on the
graph here on the side
you can see that the recovery of various
immune cell subtypes within the pvmcs
is at least as good if not even better
with the max prep pvmc isolation kit
at least when compared to density
gradient centrifugation using fico
so the kit really eliminates any user
dependent inconsistencies
and performs reliably for every
separation
and this in turn will then help you to
further standardize your t cell essays
again you can also follow the links
behind this yellow circles here on the
top to find more
more information so now after preparing
the cells for example from pbmcs
the next crucial step in the workflow is
this antigen-specific stimulation in
vitro
and here the most efficient
antigen-specific stimulation of t cells
can be achieved with our peptivator
peptide pools
these peptiberator peptide pools
efficiently stimulate both cd4 as well
as cd8 positive t
cells and we cover an extensive
portfolio of
virus two more microbiota and even auto
antigens
the peptide pools always consist of 50
meter peptides
with 11 amino acid overlaps which cover
let's say the complete sequence of the
of the studied antigen
and our pectivators are available in
research premium and even
in max gmp grade which will allow a
rapid translation into the clinic
and finally they're also available in a
convenient 96 well format for high
throughput applications
so we think our peptivators can really
help you to standardize your t-cell
assets further
and are the idle stimulation reagents
for antigen and very specific t
cells so most notably we have
many different zarsk of two peptivators
and the portfolio due to the current
situation is growing very fast
so for example we recently added the
so-called zarskov to peptidator select
which which contains immunodominant
epitopes of the whole
virus proteome so it's actually a mix a
pool of 88
structural and non-structural vascular
two peptides
importantly zascof2 select is already
available in both premium
as well as in max gmp grades of course
we also have other zarskov2peptivators
which cover different parts of the spike
protein for example
as you can see here as you can see here
on the right
however we also have specific nuclear
proteins and also membrane protein
peptidors
and as as for the whole portfolio we
will continue to develop new peptidors
for example for the news ask of the
mutation variants that currently arise
from the uk also south africa
and you can also follow the links here
to get a more
detailed overview on the on the peptidal
website also watch a very nice video
that explains the technology in more
in more detail and yeah we also
generated some exemplary data using
these ask of two peptides
and here we can see that stimulation of
t
cells results in efficient activation
so in this example we use blood samples
of healthy donors and also covert 19
survivor
they realized with rbc lysis buffer and
then stimulated for four hours
with the respective activator or left
untreated
the cells were then stained using an
optimized intracellular outstanding
protocol
and our zaskov2t cell flow panel
and here antigen-specific activation was
assessed by analyzing interferon gamma
production by cd-3 positive cells
and the plots clearly show that covid19
survivors present
elevated levels of sask of directive t
cells
following the stimulation with with with
one of the peptivators
so of course every stimulation
experiment
requires a reliable positive control and
here our cytosine reagent can further
help to standardize your t cell assays
cytostem has been specifically developed
for the rapid and efficient stimulation
of human t
cells it activates t cells by binding to
the tcr
and cross linking it with the mhc
molecules present on antigen presenting
cells
it is an antibody based reagent and can
be considered as a non-toxic alternative
to the super antigen scb
here in the graph on the site you can
see that pbmcs can be efficiently
stimulated using cytostem
and also upon stimulation with cytostem
and in the presence of antidepressant
cells cd4 and cd8 positive t
cells start to secrete cytokines such as
interferon gamma tnf alpha interleukin-2
and will upregulate activation markers
within a few hours
so cytostem really is the perfect
positive control for stimulation
of antigen and virus specific t cells so
following this stimulation we will now
take a look
at tools that can be used for
pre-enrichment of antigen virus-specific
yeast cells
so of course still flow cytometry is the
most widely used method for the analysis
of rare cells in general
however even established methods like
flow cytometry have
the limits and also challenges
especially as
antigen very specific t cells are so
extremely rare
and this was already illustrated in a
years ago
in a very nice publication by bacha and
colleagues
where they say that despite its high
sensitivity
standard flow cytometry is always
limited by the number of events that can
be acquired
as well as the staining background which
is typically between 0.01
and 0.1 so these limits really restrict
the analysis of cell populations with
such low frequencies
so all although in most instances flow
cytometers
are actually sentiment sensitive enough
to detect at least some cells
there might be certain conditions where
hardly any specific t
cell can be detected and here you can
use
our our max microbeads for
pre-enrichment
moreover to keep this background
staining at an absolute minimum
and enable a high resolution you can use
our specific labeling regions coupled to
very bright floral force
and here our recombinant reaffinity
antibodies really provide
high specificity purity and lot to lot
consistency furthermore
the recombinant design actually
completely eliminates the need for fc
receptor blocking
and further our really bright violets
can also enhance the detection
capability capabilities of these rare
cells
so we think that that for especially for
this rear cell analysis enrichment can
be the key for successful
analysis and then now let me show you
some examples
and here the results after
pre-enrichment using
our city 154 or c137 micro bits
microbead kits are really amazing so
both markers are actually up regulated
on cd4 positive and c8 positive t
cells after antigen stimulation and are
therefore really
really suited for the pre-enrichment so
in this example pvmcs were stimulated
with the cmv
with the cmv peptidator or also left
untreated as a control
then the antigen-specific t cells were
either enriched using the c154 microbead
kit for cd4 positive t cells
or the cd 137 micro bit kit for cd8
positive t
cells you set the cells with encounter
stand for cd4 and cd8
and as expected hardly any cell
expressing c154 or c137
were found in the the unstimulated
sample independent of of enrichment
however following the the stimulation
the antigen-specific t
cells heavily upregulated the respective
markers and could therefore also be
easily enriched
with the with the respective microbead
kits these isolated cells can then be
used for any downstream applications
like for example
uh sequencing of these of of these
receptors
and if you want to have a have a look at
our nice
nice tech paper here on the top this
really nicely illustrates the technology
in much
more detail so in in that in that sense
of pre-enrichment i would also like to
introduce the so-called rapid author
protocol
which is a really good solution for the
analysis of rare
and antigen virus specific t cells so
rapid arter combines
cell stimulation surface marker staining
intracellular cycle
cytokine staining with an enrichment
step based on for example cd 154
which as we just saw is a really good
marker to enrich rare cd4 positive teeth
strikingly however permeabilization and
intracellular cycle staining
can be directly performed in our max
columns during the enrichment
the saw enriched cells and stained cells
can then be eluted and easily analyzed
on standard flow cytometers like for
example on all maxwend analyzers
of course you can also modify rapid
arter for for example cd8 positive t
cells by using c1 or 137
or any other markers for enrichment so
in conclusion rapidart is not only very
fast so it only has
um it's only a one hour protocol with 30
minutes hand on hands on time
but it's also extremely sensitive due to
this enrichment process
step so now we can also have a look at
a virus specific example where the rapid
auto protocol was applied
so here pbm sees from a covert 19
survivor or healthy donor
where these are stimulated with a mix of
vascular tube activators
or in this case an influenza peptide
makes as a control
or left untreated and as seen in the
middle panel
the rares ask of directive cd4 positive
t cells
could be successfully enriched via cd154
and then easily visualized using flow
cytometry
and the data were provided with the
courtesy of alexander sheffield and
petra becca
from the university clinic in chelsea
holstein in kiel germany
and you can also have a look at their
publications listed here on the site
to find more details about the
enrichment of antigen-specific t-cells
furthermore i also want to point out a
cell separation product that is
absolutely unique
and these are the so-called cytokine
secretion assays
so cytokine secretion assays or csa
allow
the viable enrichment of cytokines for
secreting cells
from both mouse and human samples and
the principle is actually rather simple
so first the secreted cytokines are
immobilized
on the cellular surface by the so-called
cat reagent
basically thereby the cell labels itself
with its own cytokines
in the second step the immobilized
cytokines are then labeled with
fluorophore conjugated antibodies
called detection reagents and with that
living cells can then be detected
without
intracellular staining using flow
cytometry in an optional third step
the fluorophore labeled cytokine
secreting cells can then be specifically
enriched
and used for downstream assays with the
help of anti-fluorophore magnetic beads
so consequently our cytokine secretion
assays come in two versions
for flow analysis only we offer the
various detection kits
while for the enrichment and analysis of
viable cytokine cytokines
secreting cells we have several
enrichment and
detect detection kits so of course we
also generated some exemplary data with
disease a
assays and as you can see they work very
efficiently to enrich
in this case viable virus specific t
cells
based on cytokine secretion and also
here we use pbmcs
of a cmv positive donor stimulated those
pvmcs for four hours either with cmv
lysate
or a cmv peptidator the responding cells
were then isolated according to the
secretion of dnf
or gamma interferon using the respective
detection kits
and as you can see in the simulated
samples a distant population
of cytokine secreting cd4 and cd8
positive t
cells were specifically enriched whereas
in the unstimulated control sample
no cytokine secreting cells could be
detected after the enrichment
although in some cases we strongly
recommend to enrich the cells before
analysis
you can often also go ahead and stain
the cells for flow analysis
immediately after the stimulation and we
will have a look at
at our products for for flow staining
now so
as already mentioned before
we have the rear affinity antibodies and
vyodis
and i really have to have to say they
have been designed
with flow cytometry in mind so the
reaffinity antibodies are recombinantly
engineered what does this actually mean
so
simply it means that we have a full
control
over their genetic sequence and we can
express them in
mammalian non-hybridoma cell systems
and therefore they have a higher purity
and also a lot to lot consistency
compared
to conventional monoclonal hydrodoma
antibodies
furthermore they provide a really low
background staining which makes them
really good tools
for especially rare cell analysis our
biodyes on the other hand are our own
fluorescent dyes and i have to say they
work really well in conjunction
with the reaffinity antibodies they have
a very high stain index and also low
spillover
which make them a really good tool for
this clear discrimination of these very
rare cells
especially when you have a high
background
so and here we just listed several
reaffinity antibodies that could be of
interest
when analyzing antigen and virus
specific t cells
so you can join this this let's say flow
revolution
and have a look at our reaffinity
antibodies that were
really developed i have to say it again
with flow cytometry in mind
and of course we are also very happy to
help you designing your own customized
panel
so when it comes to flow analysis we of
course do not only have your infinity
antibodies and deviodize but we also
have ready to use
optimized flow kits and we'll have a
look at those now
so now let's just take another look at
our new zask of two t-set analysis kit
pbmc human that i already shortly
introduced to you in the beginning
the kit was specifically developed for
the efficient stimulation
and precise analysis of zask of
directive t cells in human pvmc
samples and is currently for research
use only
and the kit is really an all-in-one
solution it includes the sask of to
captivate of
peptide pool for antigen-specific
stimulation and also cytostem as a
positive control
it includes all eight flow antibodies
and life data that were carefully
selected and optimized to enable a
precise analysis
of these ask of directive cd4 and ca
positive t
cells and we also intentionally left one
position
free to include your own antibody of
choice
the included simulation and staining
protocol was specifically developed for
the kit
and of course the kit also contains all
required buffers
reagents such as breville and a and of
course has a very high capacity of
100 tests for up to 10 to the power of 8
cells
so here on the top you can see the
workflow of the kit
so after after isolation and stimulation
of pbmcs
with the included sask of the peptidator
the cells are stained with our
specifically optimized flow panel
shown here shown here in the table
and then analyzed using standard flow
cytometers like for example our max
quant analyzers
and it's also good to know that you can
also create
your own stimulation mix by combining
different pectivators
right now the kit is designated for pbmc
samples only however
we will soon release additional version
versions for example
whole blood kit or kids with other
peptivators
and as you can see here in the in the
plots on the on the side
the specifically activated the ask of
directive cd4 and c8 positive t cells
can be both detected in just one sample
through the combined analysis of various
activation markers like for example c1
and 54
or cytokines such as gamma interferon or
gnf alpha
of course we've also generated some data
with this kit
and in this nice example we stained
again pbmcs of
zask of directive donors after
stimulation
with the indicated with the indicated
pectivator
and then stained them with the panel
that is included in the
saskatchewan t-cell analysis kit plus
cd69 in this case
and here we use the mix of cmv and ebv
peptivators as a reactive control
so for analysis we pre-gated then on cd4
or cd8 and then assess cd154
ntnf alpha expression on cd4 positive t
cells
and cd69 and gamma interferon on cdc8
positive t
cells and as you can see t
cells respond specifically to the
stimulation with the peptivators
and then indicate exposure of the donor
to disaster of two virus
so we do not only have the the
recombinant re-affinity antibodies or
disaster futility cell analysis kit
but we also have other really convenient
ready to use flow analysis kit
for example the rapid cytokine
inspectors which are
also true all-in-one kits that allow a
rapid multi-parameter analysis
of those activated cd4 positive and cd8
positive t
cells through a combination of external
extracellular staining
and intracellular staining of of various
cytokines
we also have the the so-called max plex
cytokine kits
which are available for both human and
mouse samples
and in these kits we use multiplex
analysis
to measure concentrations of up to 12 or
10 different secrets
different secreted cytokines in cell
culture supernatants
the technology is based on our maxplex
capture beads that work with
basically any standard flow cytometer
and of course
the maxplex portfolio is continuously
growing however we already have a very
large range of different kids
such as for example for the analysis of
exosomes
or cytotoxic t cells and then last but
not least we also have the so-called
eight color immunophenotyping kit
which enables an optimized flow-based
evaluation of various leukocyte subsets
such as for example monocytes
neutrophils
eosinophils tmb cells also nk cell
populations
and of course all of these kits are
compared compatible
with our very fast and convenient
express modes
that are available on all of our maxqd
analyzers
and you you can imagine these these
express modes as some kind of software
module
that really help you to automate flow
analysis
and this will not only speed up the
whole analysis process
but also help you again to further
standardize your essays
thanks to for example automated gating
or
predefined analysis templates if you are
interested
in the express modes or the max plex
kits you can have a look at our very
nice other webinars
by following the respective links here
on the
on the side so finally
we now also take a short look
at our own very powerful cell sorter
the so-called max quant title so
the max point title also really
revolutionizes cell sorting by offering
some unique advantages
it is definitely the idle sort of
infectious samples as in in virus
research operator safety
has to come first the title really
enables safe cell sorting
as the sample stays inside a closed
cartridge system
for the entire aerosol 3 sorting process
furthermore the title is also really
gentle to your cells
it only uses very low pressure and does
not apply any charge to your cells
and this leaves the the title sword
itself so to say
in a really good condition to be used
for any downstream applications
and also the the full sterility of the
sorting process make the title really
idle
in the context of translational
applications especially in combination
with our max gmp consumables
so here the title is already part of
several clinical studies
involving for example engineered immune
cells or also car t
cells and another key advantage
of the title is its small size like all
of our max quant analyzers
and this actually makes it possible to
directly place them for example in a
flow cabinet
and let me just just briefly point out
that several titles are also being used
in the context of zaskov to research
already
so here for example for the isolation of
zlaskov to specific t
cells also the ask of two specific b
cells
so we think and we also know that our
title is a really good solution
for gentle sorting of red cells from of
course not only
but also infectious material so finally
here you can see a
nice schematic overview of our whole
antigen and virus-specific t-cell
portfolio
and the workflow and as you can see we
actually cover everything so from sample
preparation to cell culture
cell stimulation cell separation and
also cell analysis
and again if you want to have a closer
look you can have a
you can check out the the respective
application websites for anti-virus
specific t-cells
you can watch our other webinars or also
check out the large
t-cell research brochure so now
you you might want to ask is it really
all about t cells in virus research
no definitely not so of course b cells
nk certain myeloid cells also play a
central role
in viral infections in general and of
course here
mutiny also offers really nice solutions
for your virus research
regarding these other cell types so you
can here you can follow the links
to reach the respective application page
but i would
also like to show quickly show you some
of our highlight products that we have
for b-cell research
so for example we offer a large
portfolio of recombinant zaskov to
proteins
such as for example different variants
of the spike protein
the nuclear protein or even the envelope
protein
and these proteins can then for example
be used for the analysis and isolation
of zask of two specific b
cells however using our beat based
immunoassays
you can also use these recombinant
proteins to detect zaskov to specific
antibodies
so and here you can you can see an
exemplary workflow that could be applied
to
isolate the ask of two specific b cells
for example for degeneration of
monoclonal antibodies
so first the b cells would be isolated
from zarskov to split
to positive individual using for example
our
cd19 micro bit so the cells would then
be either
be stained with only floss atomic flow
antibodies
or also tetramers that were generated
with disaster of two recombinant
proteins
and the cells could then be directly
phenotype for example using flow
cytometry
or alter further expanded and also
enriched
for various downstream applications such
as for example
signal cell sequencing or b-cell
receptor cloning
and finally this could then be used to
generate
new cell lines for the production of
monoclonal antibodies
that could be used as a treatment or in
other applications
so of course this was very brief and you
can find more information by following
these links
also check out our our very new poster
where we analyze both the humeral and
cellular responses so b
cells and t cells to the us of two
encode 19 convalescent donors and of
course we will have a very specific
webinar addressing only this topic
coming up
very soon so to sum up the the
the most important message here is that
we will manage the crisis together
and there are a lot of benefits that are
coming from a comprehensive virus
specific t and visa research
for example we can clarify highly
relevant questions about reinfections
vaccines protective immunity also the
role of cross-reactive immune cells
we can use this analysis of these cells
to monitor
long-term protective immunity be it
after a natural infection
or vaccination and of course this will
then hopefully lead to a better
understanding
of the antiviral immune responses in
general
better disease prognosis better
treatment options
and then hopefully also have a better
planning certainty and a faster return
to more habitual or normal life to say
i really hope that that by now i could
convince you that miltoni covers the
complete
antigen and virus specific t and visa
workflows to support your research
so before we end please please just
acknowledge the displayed
disclaimer and then with this i would
like to close
with this very nice picture of our
company campus in burgess club
and of course you can always visit our
website to find more information on all
the
dimension workflows and products and
yeah i'm really thankful for your
attention
thank you lorenz for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions
as we have time for all right let's go
ahead and
get started so your first question runs
is
do you get the pbm fees are you using an
um are you using an initial source of
material
an enriched leukocyte sample such as
leukopaks or are you isolating them
directly
centrifuging whole blood
yeah thank you so this is indeed a very
very good question
actually so the max prep pbmc isolation
kit
has been optimized and originally
developed for the fast and untouched
isolation of pvmcs from small freshly
drawn
anticoagulated whole blood samples and
by smaller means
in the range of one to eight ml
and the good thing is that with this kit
you don't need any
radius density centrifugation so you can
directly go ahead and isolate the cells
from from all blood
yes
okay great thank you all right next
question how do you achieve efficient
stimulation
of cd8 t cells with your pectivators
um yeah so this is also a very good
question
that we often get so for the analysis of
antigen-specific
activation um blcd4 or c8 positive t
cells you always need antigen presenting
cells that will actually present
the peptides so in this case the
peptidor
so also for for cd8 and although this is
scientifically not completely known yet
how it actually works
if you um come if you co-culture
t cells and antigen present itself and
then spike in the pectivator
the apc's will present the antigen and
then activate the cd8 positive t cells
as well
and this works very well for for
intracellular antigens as well
okay great thank you now are there
similar kits
available for mouth tissues for example
enrichment kits for activated t-cells
yeah so this is uh something we are
currently working on
to say um however what we already have
is we have an
enrichment kit for cd 154
positive t cells which is the cd40
ligand
mostly to enrich antigen activated c4
positive t
cells for for human samples we in
addition have the cd137 enrichment kit
which we
at the moment do not have for mouse
samples
however you can always go go ahead and
isolate
um cd4 t cells um
with the cd4 microbeads and there we
have them both for human and for
for for urine samples or of course with
cca positive t
cells with the cd8 microbeads and they
are also available for human and most
t-cells
okay all right next question um let's
see
okay this user says thank you very much
for your presentation
can we carry out the in vivo stimulation
of these
rare cells through vaccinations
um yeah i'm not 100 sure
how i understand this question
but i will just try and answer
so of course the um especially these
aspects ii t-cell analysis kits for pbmc
samples will detect antigen-activated
t-cells
from vaccinated donors so if you have a
vaccinated patient and then you isolate
you draw blood at some some point after
the vaccination
you should be able to analyze the
reactivity of these of the donor t
cells with the components that are
included in the kids
and here what is what is really nice is
that we provide a really
pre-optimized flow panel um consisting
of eight flow antibodies
to to help you standardize your analysis
um and this is especially important i
think for for the future analysis of t
cells especially in the context of
analyzing
vaccine samples from from vaccinated
donors
great um what is the difference between
the different spike protein pestivators
yes so this is a very good question that
that we often get
so i can try and entangle that a bit for
you
so so first of all all these different
um spike protein peptidases
cover different parts of the spike
glycoprotein
so for example the pectivator protein f
covers all
predicted immunodominant dominant
domains of the spike protein
the protein s1 covers only the
n-terminal s1 domain
the peptido protein s plus covers a part
of the c terminal s2 domain of the spike
protein
and if you now would go ahead and
analyze the vaccine response for example
you would actually
combine those peptivators in a in a
stimulation mix
and then go ahead and stimulate
your sample your t cells however we will
also release other versions of the of
the spike protein peptidor
that we are currently working on
okay great thank you lorenz we have
several more questions
for you um will you release peptide
pools for the new sars cov2 mutation
variants
uh yes in fact we already released three
pactivator peptide pools for
the mutations that were originally
detected in the uk
and also the ones in south africa so the
b117 rotation into b1351 station
and it's really nice so for these these
mutation pools
we actually offer two different um
peptide pools
per variant so one is the mutation pool
which covers the the sequence of the
mutated protein
and the other is the um the respective
control pool which covers the wuhan wire
type
pool and by by a separate simulation
with this mutation and this reference
pool you
you're then able to detect and compare
these mutation specific visa responses
all right thank you moving on to your
next question
when will the whole blood kits be
available for analysis
of sars kobe 2 reactive t cells
yeah also this is a very nice question
um so actually we already released
an optimized version for whole blood
samples early in march
so you should be able to find it on the
website
and there are it's basically the same
workflow as for the pvmc kit
um but but it also includes other
reagents that are
um needed to to isolate and then
stimulate those cells from from whole
blood samples
thank you have you tried to culture
enriched activated t-cells
yes this is what we are currently
actively working on and we will
hopefully very soon release protocols
especially for the
cultivation of enriched activated
t-cells
but of course i am happy i think also in
the slicex there is already one
protocol for the expansion of
antigen-specific
t cells before stimulation if i'm not
mistaken but this i would have to
to look up but i'm very happy to come
back to you in a on a different
occasion
thank you lorenz okay we have time for a
few more questions here
um let's see how many samples can be
analyzed
using the sarskov2 t cell analysis kits
for pbmc samples
um okay so this is a rather easy one so
the kit is optimized to analyze
100 samples however for the analysis of
for example one donor sample
we always strongly recommend to have a
separate negative and positive control
so basically three samples per donor
so with which then means that with one
kit you could
analyze 33 patients and then always have
a stimulation a positive and a negative
control per patient
great thank you is the antibody panel
included in the sars kobe 2 t-cell
analysis kit flexible
enough to include own markers of
interest
um yeah definitely so um actually
intentionally in the in the pbmc version
of the kit we left one position
so the the pe vial 615 which is the the
pe sci-fi
channel um free to include your own
antibody of choice and
and here of course most relevant to to
analyze diesel activation are for
example
markers such as cd25 cb69
or other cytokines like for example
interleukin 2.
all right thank you it looks like we
have one more question here for you
do you need to activate apcs for
sufficient antigen specific
activation of t-cells
so um actually not so in the protocol
that is included in the kids
completely works out an additional
stimulation of antigen presenting cells
of course you can go ahead and also
include for example anti-cd28
in your stimulation to further boost
antigen-presenting cells and thereby
also boost
um the reactivity you will measure from
the t-cells
but for for the kids for the kids
workflow you do not need to
to separate the apc's additionally
okay great thank you lauren do you have
any final comments for our audience
before we wrap up today
um no i'm just really grateful to get
the opportunity
to to present you this data and of
course i mean
um one thing i can say is that covet
nitin is a very
fast moving topic and we at milton
are always trying to to stay stay on top
so we are currently developing many more
products for the analysis
of the ask of two specific immune cells
especially
um also vascular to specific b cells and
there will be
a webinar coming up very soon
and yeah maybe you just keep your eyes
open
and other than that just stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you very much
thank you again lorenz for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lavrutz and
our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's
educational webcast if you would like
more information
on the whole blood analysis kit please
visit their website here
in front of you and before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care and goodbye